it's found only in Venezuela in Colombia
and it's one of the rarest Crocs on the
planet launder and it may just be my
best capture ever Series II region will
only say Thursday there's huge it's a
huge croc when I finally saw that croc
and realize just how massive he was I
knew he was probably with one of the
largest wild or no goes left on the
planet somebody else is gonna have to
jump on it with me I knew we had to be
extra careful not only for our own
safety but also for the well-being of
this precious animal okay you get the
back legs keep pulling keep pulling if I
mean this croc is probably around 60 to
80 years old he's a survivor of the
slaughter that almost wiped his species
off the planet I mean it's almost like a
religious experience just to put your
hands and to feel the breath I mean it's
almost like touching a dinosaur okay we
got to try to secure these jaws but when
I finally knew we were gonna safely
gather the data
I just felt a relief in incredible
excitement okay wait a second let me
think about this that is a monster
crocodile capsule container crocodile
it's just as dangerous for the croc as
it is for us they can literally exhaust
themselves to death so anytime we
capture a truly giant crocodile such as
this an endangered species we try to
work as quickly as possible we're gonna
gather our data as fast as we can and
then we're gonna release this animal
back into the wild unharmed all right I
don't capture an animal for the sake of
television it's just too dangerous
there's always a science backbone behind
every expedition or every film that you
see on television which so what'
yourself it's in great shape we're
getting look at it it's in great shape
it's nice to capture any crocodile but
it's real special when you catch a real
giant because there are fewer and fewer
of these giant beasts still out like
giant crocodiles giant snakes are also
increasingly hard to find they've been
hunted for centuries for the skin and
meat trade and are often killed
needlessly out of fear anytime you find
a giant snake man it's like you know the
ultimate prize because they are so rare
so when snake expert Jerry Martin and I
heard from a village in India that
wanted to relocate one we responded
immediately
I've got a huge placing it's the big one
it's the big one everybody wait wait
wait don't come run it up don't come
running up I got a bad feeling about
this
okay I'm gonna find inch a little bit
for any wait wait wait let me get in a
better position whoa buddy
go go go go you got it I got him I got
him I got him I can't can't hardly hang
on you got him you sure
do it the adrenaline is just pulsing
through my body I'm so excited and
that's where you come back down to earth
real fast
y'all chewing it's like the fear factor
starts getting higher as soon as we put
our hands on it in your mind you say
uh-oh we're in way over our head this
thing is way more powerful than I
anticipated oh my gosh what's happenin
bite your face don't let him bite your
face hold that oh my god that is one
huge snake all right I've got him I got
him he's let me just get I've got his
head don't let go that head I'm afraid
that
man he's ruining cop man
this is the real biggest snake I have
ever seen
I know come on you cannot believe how
strong these snakes are I mean they're
essentially nothing but muscle I mean it
is scary strong yeah